this is where the British start to lose
me because I well there's things about
this that I can get down with and I'm
going to try it because you know what
life is
short this is like a English breakfast
right okay okay sometimes they'd serve
it with like black pudding which is like
cono blood of a pig well maybe I'll get
that on the side
think feel like a British audience can
you try and explain what lucky Chums are
yes happily I will so how I would
explain it they're sweet little cereal
with little rainbow marshmallows nice
nutritious breakfast nice super a lot of
protein oh my I like there's not even
nutrition facts on this because like
there's none magnesium and phosphorus
those things don't sound good basically
like battery acid but it's delicious and
we Americans love it